Why did you use miracles to set up a 10th place trap
?
You're being deceived to the very end. You're being chased, and you're supposed to be cooperating with the undesired liberation of the century, aren't
you?
Barusu seems to have no life
4.
[Music]
It seems that his skill in making tea didn't improve while he was away.
It
's already cute enough I can't stop saying that the world is
in danger any more.
If that's the case, it's late town, but it
's okay, but I can't speak from my mouth
.
If you did that, you would have instructed Frederica about this and that.
It's a bad guess, Frederica can't break the restrictions on her own will, so she has no
choice but to use force against
Barusu.